people don't want to tell me when I'm
like okay this is a secret door it's
just us two I promise you nobody will
ever know tell me they're scared to tell
me in that environment the thought that
you're gonna stand and buy the whole
[ __ ] company and be like that's a
quantum leap from we're on that right
now but that's where I want to go so how
do you get to run the craziest marathon
you run a lot of small races so I would
like to start making our next meetings
here where you can listen at first it's
gonna start philosophical hey Gary how
come sometimes people you know however
you want to do it that allows you to ask
the question that when they do the
happiest the question that you and your
seven homies that go out for a drink
here and hang out on the weekends
complain about this place about how do I
get you to ask me a question because the
thing that I think will stun you or make
you triple reaffirmed have the displaces
or whatever the [ __ ]
hyperbole I can say right now that
sounds good is the intent is always
right
you could you could be upset because you
think I'm stupid and I'm wrong but
that's a very different thing than the
intent and I think if I can drill that
hole we can build something very special